hello and welcome I'm Zack Parrish with
Epic Games and today we're gonna take a
look at some of the tools and features
available for Unreal Engine 4 which is
ready for download right now we're gonna
start by creating a really simple
environment just to show off how easy it
is to make world than ue4 I'll begin by
bringing in a little bit of geometry now
this is not exactly right in terms of
size for our purposes so I'm gonna scale
it down really quickly and let's snap it
right down to the floor I'll frame the
camera up on it and we have a nice solid
block and we're gonna carve out of that
so I'll make a duplicate and let's make
that duplicated subtractive now I'm
gonna resize this let's say to 480 will
do about 3 meters tall and then with
just a little bit of adjustment I can
align this with our original surface and
create a nice two walled set with a
floor and a ceiling it'd be cool if this
had a door so let's take that negative
shape we'll duplicate it and let's see
here let's make it wall thickness 150 by
about 250 it seems to be a pretty good
door height weight and and I'll just
sink this into the back wall there we go
and just like that I get a nice clean
doorway which if I wanted to I could
reposition now the materials on this are
fairly drab just having this default
material in here so I'll select one of
the back walls and we'll run a quick
algorithm to select all of the adjacent
walls and then here in my content
browser I can drag out a brick material
and you see how that quickly gets
applied to all of the wall surfaces
let's put something on the ceiling and
let's add a hardwood floor material down
on the floor which I'll quickly rotate
45 degrees just because it looks nice
now some decorations would be good so
let's see let's bring in a table and
I'll bring in a chair rotate that
slightly let's bring in another chair
there we go and some lighting would be
nice so I've got a ceiling lamp that I
can bring in now this is not a mesh this
is actually created with our blue
system which I'll talk about a little
bit later essentially that means it has
some in-game behavior already set up for
it so I can toggle it on and it starts
illuminating my scene I'll tap G to go
into game mode and hide out those
unnecessary sprites so we can see how
that looks I can also take this light
and make a duplicate of it and part of
its blueprint script means that I can
toggle its type to a floor lamp so this
one asset can serve multiple purposes we
can tap the end key and then I'll just
drag that over into the corner now let's
fill in our doorway with a door so I've
got another blueprint that I can bring
in like so now because this is a
blueprint it's more than just a static
mesh door if I hit play and just jump
right into the game you can see that the
door automatically opens and it works
from both directions because it was
already scripted to do that now the next
part of my demonstration has to do with
materials in Unreal Engine 4 we use what
are called physically based materials
this means we define our materials using
physical terms just as you would in the
real world so here I can control the
base color of this material and you see
that controls how light is absorbed next
we have roughness now this controls how
rough the surfaces at the macroscopic
level which is a really fancy way of
saying it controls how shiny it is so
you see with a low roughness value the
surface is very shiny as I increase
roughness it becomes much more dull next
we can also control how metallic a
surface is so here we have a metallic
value of zero so we have what looks like
shiny plastic as I increase the metallic
value you see we blend over to something
much more like Chrome and we can always
do more next door we have these two
materials which are a bit more complex
and are actually disrupting their
surface or perturbing the surface of
their geometry so let's take a look at
these in wireframe and you can actually
see those vertices being perturbed now
materials can also take in inputs from
cameras in the scene so here there's a
camera looking at those two previous
materials and then broadcasting that
into this material to look like a
holographic display
next to this we have an example of how
we can take a scene load it into a
material and then manipulated in this
case to make kind of a high-tech world
as you see here this material is wiping
back and forth between the actual scene
and one of the many buffers that our
rendering engine uses to draw everything
in this case we're taking a look at the
roughness buffer which is how shiny
objects are in the level materials can
also be used as layers so here we see
five rockets the four small ones each
have their own individual material types
have aluminum and then chrome and then
copper and then red plastic while the
large rocket in the center is using all
four of those as layers to cover its
surface we can also combine material
types so here we have a material with
mass capacity and two different material
types along with some animation and you
can see how that masked opacity is
blending seamlessly into the scene and
shadowing properly here we've actually
blended water and metal together to
create a bit of a complex surface with a
tremendous amount of detail if I select
this I can actually open this up in the
material instance editor and we can make
changes to the color of the surface that
update in the editor in real time or if
we wanted to make a change to the actual
behavior of the base material we could
open up the parent and make any changes
we wanted to its graph network now
materials can also respond to in-game
events so here I have three materials
being ice wood and metal and I can throw
fire at each one and they will each
respond accordingly
in their own way so you see the water
the ice melts of course the wood starts
to burn and the metal gets sherry hot
then I can splash in the water and get
an entirely different response that
blends in perfectly now let's talk about
blueprints blueprints are our visual
scripting system in Unreal Engine 4 now
earlier I was using play in editor I'm
actually going to
out of that now and we're going to
simulate an editor that means that the
game is playing while we remain behind
able to still select and work with
objects so I'll select this bouncing
ball and we'll open up its blueprint
graph here we can see what is called a
timeline driving the animation of that
ball and moving it up and down and each
time it strikes the ground we're calling
this node at the bottom which is
spawning the ripple effect that you see
I can right-click on that node and add a
breakpoint and the next time that node
executes it halts playback and jumps me
right to that location
which makes it very easy for us to debug
these graphs later on we'll go ahead and
remove that breakpoint and I'll click
resume and we can continue on now
blueprints are not just for things that
move around in your scenes we can also
use them to create powerful level design
tools so here we have a steel railing
that has a variable length I can
increase the length like so and that
length is independent for each instance
of the blueprint so I can make a copy of
it and I can lower that length or make
another copy of it and rotate it and
change that length and you can see how
very quickly I can make multiple copies
or multiple instances of this blueprint
and populate my world now blueprints can
also communicate with one another so
here I have three different blueprints I
have a button a light and some gears now
when I step on the button you'll see
that these gears start turning that's
because they have actually been told to
communicate directly with the button I
guess specifically the button has been
told to communicate with them I'm going
to jump out of the the game will select
the button now I'm going to tell it to
communicate with a light bulb instead
I'll hit play and the next time I step
on the button the light bulb lights up
but the gears remain stationary now we
can also create a eye style networks
within blueprints so here if I hit
simulate we've got this little butterfly
who's just flying around minding his own
business he actually flies around expels
energy he'll get tired and then he'll
actually halt and try to rest let's
pause the game I'll select him and open
up his blueprint graph this graph is
actually fairly expensive let's go
resume the game and it's a little far
away but we can actually see all of his
decisions cycling through his graph as
he decides to take off in another
direction as he decides to sit down and
rest so if we zoom in here on this one
aspect of the network this is just
controlling his animated material every
time that material needs to change we
can watch that code execute in real-time
while the game is playing back over in
the editor now to really drive this home
I have some games that were created
entirely within the blueprint system
you'll note that these are kind of like
games within games I can walk up to this
button and we start playing this little
Galaga style shooter that is completely
contained within our level let's jump
out of that now behind me I've got
another game you see this little UFO
when I step on the button we take over
the UFO my camera changes and my
controls become different so now I can
fly this little guy around and I can
abduct these little toy cows that you
see and eject them into their little pen
now this UFO was also created with the
blueprint system so I'm going to show
that off real quick let's actually jump
out of the game for just a moment I'm
gonna hit eject now the game continues
playing it's just I'm not controlling
anything so I can select our little UFO
and we can open up its blueprint graph
and here's everything that is going on
with just that UFO I'm gonna zoom in on
this one network over here and this is
all of the things that control its
little abduction beam and you can see
they're quite extensive there's things
for when we activate the beam deactivate
it when it actually sucks up one of the
other objects let's zoom in on just the
on and off sequence just to make that
really easy to see and I'll adjust my UI
slightly so we can see that a little
more clearly now with the UFO selected
I'll just repossess him and I can
continue playing just like nothing ever
happened so now as I activate the beam
you can watch that code
update and execute during playback and
blueprints made this possible for just a
couple of artists to put these together
both of the games you see here we're
really just the effort of one to two
artists and require no programmers
whatsoever and the best part is these
are not all individual disparate parts
we can take our UFO and fly it back to
the scene and still see everything
working fly back through all of our
materials even go back and explore that
little environment that we made and
everything just works and it's
interactive and of course we all like
blowing things up so as a finale let's
just fly into this logo and you can see
that that's a destructible mesh so now
that you've seen a nice selection of
tools and techniques for Unreal Engine 4
let's show you what a small team can
accomplish with it so this was a little
project put together by just a few of
our artists in their spare time now here
we are in the editor I'm actually going
to hit play and leave this in the editor
[Music]
so that wraps up this demonstration
remember Unreal Engine 4 is available
right now for download $19 a month plus
5% of your gross if you ship a title
thanks very much for your time and we
hope to see you around